every movie I've ever done has had an
IMAX release from 300 on I've been 100%
invested in IMAX as a format and as a
way of seeing a movie when the screen is
so big the detail that you see but also
the breadth of the spectacle that you
see it's unmatched the greatest
gladiator match in the history of the
world the experience is more immersive
it is the way I attend the movie to be
seen so when you've seen it and I'm
actually seeing the purest form of the
movie with Batman V Superman it was the
first time that we got to use the IMAX
cameras and to actually shoot 30 minutes
of the movie with the IMAX cameras on
such a big frame just the detail and the
blacks and the whites and the richness
of the color is pretty amazing he's the
one that brought the war to us and then
when it jumps up to the one 4:3 ratio
when you got this big giant square it's
such an immersive experience it's an
amazing way to visualize and it's fun to
shoot a really intricate sequence with
those cameras part of you done
once you get used to it it's just a tool
to make something awesome and I loved
1:43 I loved the big square we decided
when we were using the IMAX cameras that
we would bookend the film so right at
the very beginning it would be an
immersive experience and also at the end
of the movie it would be an immersive
experience and then the two biggest
fight scenes
we also shot with IMAX cameras it's
unforgettable when you see a movie like
this on a screen like that people see
movies all the time but they haven't
seen IMAX or gone to an IMAX movie
lately you need to go back and remember
what that is because it's like another
thing okay I saw movie
now I'm really seen
you